WHAT is COREPER?
You may not have heard of Coreper, but it
is an important body at the heart of EU policy-making.
Coreper stands for the Committee of the Permanent
Representatives of the 28 governments that
make up the European Union.
It prepares the work that allows Europe's
ministers and leaders to take important policy
decisions that impact on the lives of Europe's
500 million citizens.
WHO works in COREPER?
Coreper is made up of the permanent representatives
- ambassadors - and their deputies from the
member states. They help ensure that national
concerns are taken into account in European
policy-making.
Formally they meet in Brussels once a week,
but in reality the representatives talk to
each other every day.
Their sessions are held in two formats - Coreper
2, composed of the permanent representatives,
and Coreper 1, made up of their deputies.
Together, these two formats cover all the
different EU policy areas.
WHAT do they do exactly?
Their job is to prepare the meetings of the
Council of the European Union.
The Council is the body where ministers discuss,
debate and decide EU policy on topics ranging
from fisheries to safety legislation, from
the banking union to trade.
Decision-making is left to ministers, but
Coreper plays an important role in preparing
the choices for them.
Through its work, Coreper identifies areas
of agreement and disagreement between different
national positions.
It tries to find ways for differences to be
resolved, and clarifies the choices for ministers
ahead of their meetings.
Coreper is also tasked with implementing ministers'
and leaders' instructions.
HOW does it all work then?
Work often begins weeks or months before the
Council meeting.
Discussion is based on the preliminary efforts
of more than 150 working groups and committees.
Throughout its work, Coreper members are in
constant contact with their national governments
in their capitals.
Quite often, all this careful preparation
leads to an outcome that is generally agreed.
In these cases, discussion agreed in Coreper
can become a so-called 'A' item on the Council
agenda.
That means it is passed to ministers for decision
without further debate, unless a country specifically
requests one.
Sometimes Coreper cannot reach agreement because
more technical work is required. In this
case, it can send the issue back to the experts
in the working parties.
For many issues however, reaching an agreement
requires ministers to make choices and give
political input.
These issues are sent by Coreper as so-called
'B' items on the Council agenda, for discussion
at ministerial level.
So that, in a nutshell, is Coreper. For more
information, take a look at the Council's
website.